hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today I'm talking to David post of
Temple University and the author of
Jefferson's mousse notes on the state of
cyberspace David thanks for coming thank
you what was Jefferson's mousse and why
is it so important to you that you had
to name your book after Jefferson's
moose was a moose the American moose
that Jefferson had shipped to him in
Paris when he was serving as the
American ambassador in Paris we
assembled in his the entry lobby of his
residence and the put on display for the
Parisians to come see why it's
interesting and important to me I guess
if I could explain that quickly I
wouldn't even know Brooke I suppose but
it turns out the moose was really
central to some very interesting
Jefferson the plans and and ideas and
thoughts and it symbolized strangeness
it's a my strangeness newness of the new
world that was part of the program was
to was to show the European to get them
to believe in the newness of the place
part of it was just as science Jefferson
was really interested in large animals
he was interested in the laws of nature
that governed scaling in the natural
world how things get big this is central
to cyberspace right i mean because what
works on a small scale doesn't
necessarily work on a big scale correct
cyberspace is as big as our imaginations
to use a cliché is a cliche but i think
that's right energy but but only if it
actually can scale and in our
imagination scale we can imagine perhaps
something but it actually has to do the
work i mean one of the things with
thinking about scale on the net is that
how did it get how did the internet get
so big how did it manage the rather
house did it in the terms of because one
of the themes in your book which is also
a Jeffersonian theme which is that small
units are more capable of reg self
regulation or of creating some kind of
order and now
we have a global network that was not
really designed by anybody and it's not
completely ruled by anybody right so is
cyberspace working and as it scales up
well i mean i think it is working as it
scales up i think that one of the
lessons from cyberspace is you know I
talked about in the book Jefferson
helped figure out how to scale
republican government up I think the
problem is traditionally small exactly
to national like the idea many people
believe that it was sort of a law that
they wasn't going to work in large
communities it couldn't work over large
spaces and Jefferson helped really
destroy that idea and scale from
Atlantic to the Pacific it's a
remarkable achievement and I think
cyberspace governance in a sense the
builders of the net managed to scale to
a global scale the governance mechanisms
that at least built the the protocols
quite a remarkable one of the
interesting points in your store you in
your book you talk about the way that
laws in cyberspace are the the
capabilities of cyberspace inter
intersect and interact with kind of
terrestrial based government or
governance so for instance Yahoo Yahoo
various auction sites on yahoo will
offer Nazi memorabilia for collectors
but then in certain countries France
Germany etc this is illegal so how does
cyberspace negotiate its its peace
treaties with terrestrial government
well that that is the many billion
trillion dollar question the
conventional system it doesn't work very
well I mean I think that it is a boo-boo
describing what it's what I call
jurisdictional whack-a-mole you know
it's just wherever you pop out you know
France will assert jurisdiction because
you are sending in unlawful material and
then if you pop up in some place where
they can grab you know poem that are
going to get you um and on a global
scale with multi with a more complicated
transactions it just doesn't form a
workable legal system the peace treaty
right there are no institutions in
cyberspace really that one could appeal
to for a peace treaty em I think how it
works actually is that courts in the
real world
at some points in to some extent this
this has already happened we'll defer in
appropriate circumstances to the rules
that are set in online communities I
don't think that is far-fetched is that
a good thing or a bad thing so let's say
you know France has anti Nazi
memorabilia laws so Yahoo will block
Nazi stuff going to French IP addresses
or something but then what about China
because there you have a question of the
government saying we do not want certain
types of behavior certain types of
thoughts represented right no I would I
would I would back up a little bit i
mean i don't think yahoo has an
obligation to comply with french law any
more than it has an obligation to comply
with saudi arabian law or brazilian law
and i think a world in which we are all
the thing about the net is that we're
all subject to everybody's lower by that
rationale and it can't be that I'm
simultaneously subject to 180 countries
law the deference I think comes when and
if there are serious self-governing
communities on the net which we don't
really have now I think it's fair to say
but which are one might be able to
imagine into existence and they so
there's some fraud I use the example a
second like the virtual world is some
fraud takes place in second life and
somebody comes to the district court
here in Washington DC and says give me a
remedy against this for vigilant actor
and the court says well you know second
life has a system for dealing with this
and it's reasonable and it reflects the
views of the people who are interacting
in second life so maybe if they've
already had an adjudication about this
and decided you're in the wrong we're
not going to step in and and once they
do that that becomes sort of a
triggering event for a sort of serious
law to develop in these communities what
is the state of freedom and liberty and
cyber spaces it's still growing or some
critics worry that it's being fettered
by commercial interests or state
interests I think it's worrisome I'm
glad critics are worried about the state
of freedom
on cyberspace I think both the
commercial interests are troublingly
concentrated in terms of the the basic
infrastructure of the net I think has
become controlled by a small number of
entities and that's always a different
range from comcast cable company to
Google or whoever right running running
that narrow range of people who have
their hands on the levers of
indispensable resources for Internet
communication that what troublesome what
is going to be the big cyberspace
related issue in the Obama for the Obama
administration I mean I think it's net
neutrality quite honestly I don't I go
both ways on the net neutrality issue
net neutrality meaning a rule that would
prohibit service providers from
discriminating amongst different
messages that are coming across so
putting some in high quality messages
low quality putting min isn't something
that the market would sort out though
where you would either if you're like
truncating other people's messages
nobody would use you well or they would
be willing to pay for that well that's
what I mean and people maybe be bouma
certainly are willing to pay for example
for for network services that give you a
greater quality service guarantee then
the internet now does nothing wrong with
that the problem is that then if you
start crowding up the network machines
with doing a lot of work the thing that
makes a net so extraordinary is that
it's a dumb network it's a stupidest
network imaginable it just moves bits
around it lets all the processing take
place at the endpoint the users once you
start making those Network machines
discriminate that's additional
processing you got to check what Q is it
in who's got it etcetera possible
problem okay we are going to end it
there David post thank you so much for
coming in ankeny i'm nick gillespie with
reason TV and we've been talking with
David post of Temple University Law
School and the author of Jefferson's
mousse notes on the state of cyberspace